[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture au
programme aujourd'hui c'est une
véritable enquête en ligne que vous
proposez archives départementales
objectif retrouver huit portes temporel
sur le territoire celi agathe sango
journalistes pour tv 78 a testé pour
vous ce jeu concours
le youtuber dit koch prépare sa première
réalisation elle s'intitule les
aventures de bandits vous de melun le
tournage s'est déroulé pendant cinq
jours dans le quartier du bois de
l'étang
et puis avec la crise sanitaire
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à saint quentin en yvelines
s'est adapté elle a réalisé une
captation du concert de musique
classique un enregistrement à
destination des élèves de
l'agglomération et je vous le disais en
titre les archives départementales des
yvelines lance un nouveau jeu de piste
en line lady l'énigme les huit portes
qui se déroule jusqu'au 17 avril
prochain permet de mener tout simplement
des recherches dans les documents
d'archivés numériques
notre journaliste célia gars tsongo a
testé pour vous aux archives
départementales des yvelines ce nouveau
jeu ouvert à tous regardés
[Musique]
nous sommes aux archives départementales
des yvelines en compagnie de mathilde
donjon un jour vous êtes en charge du
développement des publics
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer un peu comment fonctionne ce
nouveau jeu numérique qui s'appelle les
livres lui porte
oui alors les niveaux les victoires
c'est une énigme en ligne une enquête
entièrement sur internet qui est ouverte
à tous et qui a démarré le 17 mars
dernier qui se terminera le 17 avril 1
est-ce que vous pouvez nous montrer
comment parisienne avec plaisir à les
battre artistes alors déjà commencé pour
pour accéder à ce jeu wii
alors il faut se connecter sur le site
internet des archives départementale des
yvelines
sur la page d'accueil
une information alors un appareil un
vous cliquez sur cette information et
vous arrivez sur la page dédiée vous
arrive et on vous explique le scénario
en fait on va partir dans une enquête
avec une journaliste d'investigation qui
s'appelle léa pinatar et 7 les lapines
attar a reçu une lettre d'un certain
victor victor georget et soul eater jour
j'ai lu fait part d'un document
extraordinaire qui parle de vie porte
temporel qui se trouvent sur le
territoire des yvelines il aurait déjà
retrouvé la trace de quatre de ses
portes temporal vous serez donc dans la
peau de l'oea et c'est à vous de prendre
la suite de l enquête
une fois qu'on l'a pris connaissance du
scénario on peut commencer le jeu du
joueur se retrouve dans la situation de
quelqu'un en salle de lecture
il a commandé de nombreux cartons
archives
il va falloir qu'ils commencent à ouvrir
droite et à regarder ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur de ces boîtes alors
évidemment il ya un ordre déjà il faut
trouver les bonnes boîtes c'est un jeu
très réaliste comme si on se retrouvait
réellement salle de lecture avec des
documents un conseil prendre des notes
dès le départ c'est un jeu qui est fait
aussi pour découvrir l'initiation à la
recherche historique un peu vraiment
pour ça qu'on l'a créée donc l'idée
c'est de découvrir de se plonger
vraiment dans des documents qui sont de
réels document histoire d'apprendre ce
que c'est que la recherche est
évidemment quand on fait la recherche
d'un et d'un c'est ça on apprend à
apprendre le temps une fois que vous
avez fini toutes ces énigmes vous
envoyer un formulaire pour valider votre
participation au concours via des lots à
gagner
tout à fait en fait il ya deux
catégories dans ce concours il ya une
catégorie grand public et une catégorie
collégiens des yvelines qui récompense
chacun 30 jours
dans chaque catégorie et parfois on va
là tu es très bon dos des ordinateurs
des tablettes des vélos -l'un peut-être
ma musique donc sa mémoire les
collégiens mais aussi les troubles en
libye et le grand public tout à fait en
tout ce sont 60 gagnants
soyez tout de même patient il faut
compter trois heures pour faire
l'intégralité du parcours bien moi c'est
bon j'ai défini les lignes m'avait
envoyé mon formulaire et puis maintenant
passé à vous tourner le pilote d'une
série tournée à la verrière le youtuber
dit koch prépare sa toute première
réalisation intitulée à les aventures de
bandits goût de melun le tournage s'est
déroulé pendant cinq jours dans le
quartier à du bois de l'étang un projet
a soutenu par le producteur et
réalisateur verrier juan nadir youlin un
reportage de nicolas dans de les
regarder
il est habitué à tourner et écrire des
sketches pour sa chaîne youtube dit koch
cumule aujourd'hui plus de 250 mille
abonnés l'artiste s'est lancé un nouveau
défi réaliser un pilote d'une série
intitulée les aventures de bandits goût
de melun un jeune des quartiers
originaire de melun
il est persuadé que ça un chevalier il
va partir dans des croisades contre 70
contre le contrôle 94
il va lurel encore pâle aventures de
malades et on a on a choisi de changer
de 78 voilà la verrière pour parce que
voilà on a un cadre idéal
l'idée c'est de voile a joué sur l'école
moderne anciens de la cité de 2,2 ce que
j'ai pu connaître aussi et s'amuser avec
et faire quelque chose de joyeux plutôt
que montrer tout le temps le même image
même image de la cité 10 cocher son
équipe de tournage ont choisi la
verrière pendant cinq jours ils se sont
installés au coeur du quartier pour
enregistrer plusieurs séquences
notamment cette scène avec des cheveux
ou bondigoux rentrer dans ce fast-food
le tournage à la verrière un choix
facilité aussi par le producteur et
réalisateur originaire de la ville
nadir youlin les dianes c'était quand
même de trouver un endroit où
un quartier populaire avec des bâtiments
en perspective est aussi un bois lac
pour un peu dépaysé
et tout ça questions de logistique c'est
ce qu'ils avaient plus pratique le plan
artistique du conseil et gestion ramener
les meilleurs les meilleures personnes
pour cet endroit là leur proposer dès
leur proposer des lieux qui conviennent
au scénario qui l'ont écrit donc comme
moi je connais parfaitement les lieux de
saint quentin en yvelines et là en
l'occurrence tu bois de l'étang
je visualise les lieux je leur propose
je les amène sur les lieux ce tournage
l'occasion aussi pour nadir youlin et
son association pour la création et
l'innovation artistique et culturelle de
faire découvrir les métiers du cinéma
aux habitants de la verrière de son côté
dit koch prévoit la sortie du premier
épisode de sa série cet été sur sa
chaîne youtube dit koch tv l'association
pour la promotion de la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines s'adapte crise
sanitaire oblige impossible de se
produire devant un public
l'association a donc enregistré en vidéo
son traditionnel concert de musique
classique qui est destiné aux élèves de
l'agglomération
un reportage et d'eléonore si nos quais
et matteo luxe euros
[Rires]
[Musique]
devant l'impossibilité de renouveler ses
concerts avec public l'association pour
la promotion de la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines à trouver une
solution au lieu d'accueillir près de
4000 enfants des écoles de
l'agglomération
elle a enregistré le concert en vidéo
les 25 et 26 mars dernier cette année le
covin aux interdit d'avoir les enfants
et les personnes dans la salle donc on
fait l'un vers ce cirque on va amener l
orchestre dans les familles et dans les
écoles qu'on pourrait dire avec un peu
d'humour que avant le faisaient plutôt
façon théâtre et là on le fait plutôt
façon cinéma
objectif faire découvrir la musique
classique dès le plus jeune âge à des
élèves qui n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité d'en écouter et pour peut
être aussi susciter des vocations
la barrière qui empêche les enfants de
faire de la musique classique on pense
qu'elle est financière et n'est pas
financière elle est culturelle et donc
c'est tout l'objet de la paix mais ce qu
de porter la culture dans les milieux où
elle a de la peine à arriver
une quarantaine de musiciens de
l'ensemble instrumental de lavilledieu
étaient donc présents pour cette
captation vidéo au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et au
conservatoire de trappes cette année ils
ont joué le concerto pour piano d'edvard
grieg un grand compositeur norvégien
déjà la partie de piano et très théâtral
comme vous verrez très virtuose
l'orchestré un orchestre au grand
complet avec des vents des bois des
cuivres percussions cordes et c'est une
oeuvre qui s'enracine dans les mélodies
populaires et et molly populaire parle
aux enfants
la vidéo du concert sera mise en ligne
prochainement sur le site internet de la
paix m excuse
l'association va également contacté les
enseignants de saint quentin en yvelines
pour la diffuser au maximum auprès des
plus jeunes la barbacane en partenariat
avec la compagnie on off vous propose de
commander et des chansons à destination
de vos proches ça se passera le samedi à
10 avril quatre chanteurs et chanteuses
enfourcheront leur mobylette pour livrer
votre surprise
l'offre est gratuite et sera disponible
sur quatre communes marc toi rice au
marché et milliers lemahieu
[Musique]
il s'agit de d'apporter des chansons à
domicile d'être des messages est un peu
comme les livreurs de fleurs de pizza
sushi sauf colère là il s'agit de
chansons ça va de jane très récents ou à
schubert en passant par david bowie
[Musique]
qaïda gelly mais livré par exemple qui
marche très très bien avec le deuxième
tome de la reine des neiges les chansons
sont pas gratuites elles sont offertes
pavin macal qui via nous deux offrent la
possibilité d'offrir une chanson
gratuitement je vous invite à vous
sauter sur cette occasion de faire un
cadeau qui restera mémorable tendant de
londres lausanne et nous arrive
quelquefois de revoir les personnes qui
ont reçu une chanson et qui s'en
souviennent encore parce que c'est
c'est unique et à plus forte raison en
ce moment c'est tout à fait particulier
et nous respectons les gestes barrières
et évidemment pour commander votre
chanson il suffit de contacter la
barbacane choisissez votre chanson un
créneau et un destinataire et puis
l'équipe s'occupera ensuite ensuite de
livrer votre surprise plus
d'informations bien sûr sur le site de
la barbacane elles ne s'étaient pas
retrouvés ensemble sur scène depuis le
mois de décembre la semaine dernière les
sea girls étaient accueillis en
résidence au théâtre alexandre dumas de
saint germain en laye l'équipe a répété
son cinquième spectacle anthologie ou
presque
elles sont chanteuses et comédiennes les
sea girls ont posé leurs valises au
théâtre de saint germain en laye le
temps d'une semaine
objectif répéter leur nouveau spectacle
anthologie ou presque un théâtre musical
dans lequel elles reprennent des
morceaux de leur répertoire
une anthologie pompeuse et déjanté
d'après les artistes on peut ce parce
qu'évidemment une anthologie c'est les
beatles qui font une anthologie les
seagulls pourrait vraiment se passer
d'une anthologie mais non elle ne se
passe jamais deux de ce genre de deux
bombes ont donc nous voilà
chantant des chansons que nous avons
chanté lors des précédents spectacles
pour pour le plaisir de revisiter ses
titres des titres qui abordent des
thèmes sérieux traité avec légèreté
parmi les chansons de leur répertoire
les sea girls au pouvoir ou encore
boudin
allo
[Musique]
d'une chanson un petit peu grinçant sur
votre vie pourrie donc on parle vous
avez été frappé par votre mari vous êtes
un sdf
vous vous ne mangez pas vous êtes avez
des problèmes d'anorexie mentale mais
c'est pas grave un peu du mont ça c'est
la vie mis mon va tout réparer comme les
sea girls the le théâtre alexandre dumas
accueille des artistes chaque semaine
l'équipe met à disposition le plateau
pour leur permettre de répéter ça permet
aussi de garder le lien avec les
artistes et d'occuper aussi toute notre
équipe au théâtre notamment l'équipe
technique qui qui est donc ravis de
pouvoir contribuer aux répétitions à la
création spectacle autant au niveau du
son la lumière platon les seagulls était
en résidence au théâtre alexandre dumas
du 22 au 26 mars
le spectacle devrait être visible par le
public la saison prochaine c'est la fin
de ce set 8 culture merci de nous avoir
suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78 et d'ici
là
portez vous bien
[Musique]